بعد ايام من استهداف سد كخوفكا والاضرار
الناتجه عنه تتصاعد اعمده دخان تنذر
بماسات جديده استهداف جزء من اطول خط
انابيب للامونيا في العالم بطول
2470 كيلومترا في منطقه خاركيف الاوكرانيه
هذا الخط يمد العالم بالامونيا الضروريه
للزراعه لكنه بمثابه قنبله موقوته تزداد
المخاوف من التسبب في اضرار جسيمه للناس
والبيئه بسبب استهدافه الامونيا يمكن ان
تؤدي الى فشل الجهاز التنفسي في حال
استنشاقها اما في حاله التعرض لها كمركب
سائل فستؤدي الى تاكل الاعضاء التي تتعرض
لها وعند الانفجار في خط الانابيب يجب
اتخاذ خطوات فوريه ومحدده لضمان سلامه
الافراد وتقليل التاثير البيئي واصلاح
الضرر
اخلاء المنطقه المجاوره ثم الاستجابه
للمواد الخطره وهذا يحتاج الى فرق المواد
الخطره المتخصصه للتعامل مع الموقف احتواء
التسرب ومنع انتشار الامونيا قد يشمل ذلك
قطع الامداد اذا كان ذلك امنا واستخدام
التقنيات ومواد محدده للحد من انتشار
الغاز قد تحتاج السلطات الى توسيع منطقه
الاخلاء حسب شده التسرب على المتخصصين
تقييم الاثار البيئيه الفوريه والمحتمله
على المدى الطويل للانفجار والتسرب يمكن
ان يساعد ذلك في توجيه عمليه التنظيف
والتدابير الوقائيه المستقبليه على
المتخصصين تنظيف المنطقه المصابه وتطهير
اي معدات او هياكل او ارض متاثره
بالامونيا
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات